I love I love this lesson it's so good I
everytime I've taught it I don't know
how many times I've taught it now it's
it's always a great moment to be able to
say not everything in mathematics has an
application out in the real world that
is so obvious it's actually an
interesting kind of exercise to be able
to say things that we often don't think
have applications out in the real world
they often do they're just kind of you
know hidden away or we haven't
discovered them yet just go to sleep
here thank you
but other ones it's like yeah it's there
staring you in the face and we've been
taking advantage of it for decades
sometimes even centuries so satellite
dishes satellite dishes every single one
is what we call a parabolic dish a
parabolic dish which is to say if you
were to put a cross section across the
middle through that that center point
there and the cross section would be a
parabola I know it doesn't look sort of
super parabola ish but that's because
what we focused on there is just like
this bit down the bottom right so it's
part of a really big parabola as it were
if you have a look at a head light and I
know this is not an amazing image but
it's the one that gave me the sort of
the best view into the actual thing
you'll notice that all headlights are
also the same it's easier to see on some
than others what you'll find is that the
overall headlight you can see that sort
of that curvature inside and the actual
light the thing that produces protons
right is not the whole thing it's just
something in here that's the only spot
that's actually producing light and
everything else is just reflecting it
now the question of course is why why do
we keep using this shape over morning
over and over again to explain why in
fact we're going to do more than explain
why we need to investigate some things
about the geometry of this shape and
this is the first thing that I want you
to write down maybe the beside where
you've drawn your parabola thinking
about the best way to write this here's
I'm going to say four words which is
curved global flat local so this is the
most succinct way I can explain a
particular characteristic of this shape
in fact a characteristic of a lot of the
shapes that we've dealt with which is
gonna be the primary thing we're going
to take advantage of today what this
means is when you have a look at a
parabola overall this is clearly a
curved shape right but that's only
because of the scale on which you're
looking at it you're looking at it as it
were on a global scale you're looking at
a large part of the object but if you
were to zoom into a small section if you
were to look locally you won't observe
no curve it or and this is very easy to
illustrate I mean you can imagine it but
we don't have to imagine it if I take a
spot like this right have a look at this
now have a look at this particular
component of the parabola ah you can
still make out the curve can't you just
barely but if I go in a little further
huh you mean you want to tell you know
around no more seats left sorry I'm
right across that's why I don't know how
far what's that point five one point
five one so we're sort of far in but
we're not nearly as far as we could go
if I go in even further like that all
right what did I do I did like two two
zooms in right I well that's okay with
that there with the ruler there you can
just barely perceive a curve right just
barely but only because the ruler is
there once I take it away I mean my eyes
certainly cannot tell if I hadn't known
from the beginning that this is curved
okay yeah yep okay that's a great
question right now let me answer that
question in a second like what why does
it become a straight object let me just
point out that this is actually
something in our daily experience
because we live on an object that is
curved globally like we actually call it
a globe because
is globe-shaped but we experience it as
flat because locally on the scale that
we experience it looks pretty flat out
there to me doesn't it okay so this is
actually a matter of scale and it's
because these objects let me zoom back
out these objects in Euclidian geometry
are what we call smooth shapes right
think about all the shapes that you know
all the shapes with we've curves in them
so circles and ellipses and a like and
of thing if you zoom in far enough the
thing that they all have in common is
this that while they were curved will
overlay their flat locally okay now this
is not always the case this is just a
bit of a side note but there are lots of
shapes in reality that are not like this
for example what is this what's it look
like this looks like um these are inner
Delta's right so you've got like a
coastline you've got like sea somewhere
down here and this is where it's sort of
going inland okay now one of the
characteristic things about nature is
that often it's not you know one thing
globally and then a different thing
locally the the further you go into this
the further you zoom in and even when
you're like on the UM on the scale of
you and I on the ground okay if you go
and find where this water is seeping
into the earth you will find this exact
shape right
like I could zoom in and dig into some
tree roots and I would find water
seeping in exactly this pattern so it's
not as though you zoom in and you get
something that's dramatically simpler in
real life dolphinese zoom in and you
just get something which is more and
more complicated if you're a disc grown
fan you might say it's Turtles all the
way down okay
we call this fractal geometry it's all
broken that's what characterizes it that
it looks like this weird broken shape
all the way okay so not all geometry is
like this so you need to recognize that
but when it is we can take advantage of
things here's how let's go back to here
if I were to take like this portion over
here okay and say all right if i zoom in
far enough it's going to look like a
straight line right what that means is
and I'd love you to draw this on your
parabola as well what this means is if
you take a 10
is my tangent and I'm going to draw the
parabola as well because in a second and
turn this projector up if you take this
tangent at this point remember the
exercise I went through before if I
zoomed in so that all I could see with
this is tiny little spot right because
the parabola becomes more or less a
straight line you won't be able to
really distinguish it from the tangent
that's next to it does that make sense
because the tangent is itself a straight
line okay which means that at that point
I can treat the parabola as if it were
that tangent okay the tangent becomes an
approximation for the curve and that's
what's going to prove for us this
reflective property of parabolas okay
that this is why you'll see the picture
in a minute why we design things using
this shape because it reflects things in
a certain way so at the moment you've
got your parabola you've got a tangent
we need to put a couple more items on to
you to prove what we're after okay so
onto here what I'd like you to add on is
the focus of this parabola now I'm just
going to roughly place it around there
will do for me okay